[Musique]
après avoir sillonné toutes les routes
de france le cirque paradiso a posé ses
valises ici dans le berry ce lieu dédié
au cirque est un endroit magique où le
temps d'un rêve je vais me plonger en
immersion dans l'univers du cirque dans
l'univers du cirque ont des mutants
parce que vous voir le niveau d'éveil
pour voir ce qu'ils font je sais pas si
c'est des êtres humains
bonjour et bienvenue sous le chapiteau
du cirque paradiso sur france 3 centre
val de loire vous allez pouvoir
applaudir laura sur sa pole dance de
williams sur son rouleau américain
natacha avec son numéro de pointe à
pointe et notre grande star du jour
kamini
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette source à la maison je vous le dis
moi pourquoi avoir choisi moelleux
mairie et bien en fait on a cherché
pendant très très longtemps un lieu et
cette petite ferme ici nous attendons
jeu les deux m'ont posé la question
pourquoi avoir choisi le berry que tu
lit dans les pensées en fait c'est ça
évidemment ils ont des pouvoirs cette
passion pour le cirque chef du commun
mes parents mon nez au cirque amar quand
j'avais 4 ans et je suis sortie du
chapiteau j'ai dit ça c'est ça ma
victoire benjamin alors pas du tout si
ma fille veut faire du cirque pour en
faire avec grand plaisir et si elle à
paris elle fera autre chose ils ont des
pouvoirs ce moment la question que
j'avais posé bon allez kamini assez
parlé le spectacle continue et voici à
la pole dance laura est non la vache a
été par la terreur
ils ont des pouvoirs
pour le commenter a appris à contrôler
ce genre de pouvoir lancer d'agim ceku
tu as fait beaucoup de gym est tous dans
la jeunesse nathalie on est jongleur
acrobate et papa et maman c'était quoi
leur spécialité par spécialité leurs
pouvoirs étranges ma maman avait des
chimpanzés et toute ma famille du côté
non papa est spécialisé dans les animaux
marins qui communiquent avec les animaux
oui au salon mal tonton joie ses vignes
homme et vous êtes rencontrés dans
l'univers du cirque exactement à l'âge
de 13 ans love story bon en tout cas
bravo pour cette démonstration de pole
dance mais emploi essayer de regarder
nicolas le cadreur donc pas amoureux
[Musique]
à moi on peut rajouter une balle c'est
une non j'ai encore besoin de mes genoux
pour faire cabinet en roue libre dans ma
famille se pratiquait déjà les
disciplines où moi c'est simplement par
passion du cir j'allais toujours voir
des supers cirque c'est un peu la même
histoire que l'oncle ben après j'ai
rencontré laura dans un cirque également
été choisi et des histoires d'amour a
pour tous les styles et matière du
centre val de loire
ww.carrefour.fr peut-être vous trouverez
l'âme soeur et vas-y on voit la balle là
elle est lourde elle va du roi
[Musique]
voilà les américains quelle bande de
menteurs et wonder woman à la american
adventures roumaine aller dans le berry
il n'y a pas d'effets spéciaux ici ils
ont des pouvoirs tu me vient d'où
natacha déjà sur riise miss donc wonder
woman et russes je suis vraiment désolé
les américains aiment selon lui quand
est ce que tu as intégré la troupe du
paradiso en 2015 pour faire quelques
mois quelques mois mais étaient restés
pour l'amour
vous voulez dire pour les célibataires
de centre-loire w de vous lever pour un
cirque point fr il ya de l'amour dans
l'air lorsque je rencontre ici votre
clown préféré tout à fait benjamin vu
qu'elle a une mâchoire en métal le
premier baiser c'était a su gérer en
moins de talent
et bien j'étais vraiment ravi de
rencontrer tous ces super héros qui sont
cachés ici dans le berry visiblement ils
ont envie que je parte les gars je dirai
à personne que wonder woman et russe et
qu'elle habite dans le berry je vais
aller nettement moscou